what's going on theo brandon big griff
stevie i got the king of the stinger for
you guys
[ __ ] pumpkins
every time my girl goes to the store she
comes back with the
our doormats
my girl too man our [ __ ] looks like a
goddamn haunted house she does i love it
shoot us all out my kids love it are you
doing a haunted house this year we i did
it uh last week i went to horror nights
universal was it good wait wait you went
you went to horror nights
that was a few years ago and that was in
costa rica i went to horror nights
universal stuff but he said horror
nights no he said horror you know what i
realized i i'm too old for haunted
houses the dude rolls his r's he rolls
his bells
yeah
yeah yeah but you know it doesn't count
for you because you have kids yeah so
like so
it's for them
but this guy i don't know if this guy
has kids this guy this guy he's dating a
kid you know what i mean
what do you think about this because
you're orange they talk about orange
things i like it i like it i think it's
you know she's you know she's getting
seasonal with it did you decorate the
apartment
what did you just say well stevie's
house already has like that haunted
fired up
[Music]
is
[Music]